in this video I want to talk a little
bit about an introduction to
photosynthesis sometimes we think about
photosynthesis being sort of the reverse
of a cellular respiration it's not
exactly the case but as far as writing
the equation it's sort of backwards so
what we're going to do this is the
general scheme of photosynthesis we're
going to take carbon dioxide and water
turn it into oxygen and glucose more
specifically we're turning this water
into this oxygen and that would be an
oxidation reaction right we're losing
those hydrogen's from water and we're
making more bonds to oxygen and more
specifically this is part of the light
reaction which we'll get into in just
just a second of a photo synthesis the
other portion that we're taking these
carbons and we're fixing them or these
carbon dioxide excuse me and fixing them
into glucose and that of course we're
adding these hydrogen's here we're
adding hydrogen's to this carbon dioxide
turning it over here so this is going to
be a reduction reaction and this is
actually going to be part of the dark
reaction of photosynthesis which brings
me to this this idea of these two
processes so the two processes of
photosynthesis or the light reaction or
the light dependent reaction and the
dark reaction which is the light
independent reaction so as you may have
guessed the light reaction actually
requires light it's light dependent okay
and the dark reaction does not require
light it's light independent but you'll
see that there's a small subtlety that's
important there let me start off with
talking about the light reaction the
light reactions purpose or function is
to use light energy energy from light
which makes sense right it's the light
dependent reaction it uses light energy
to power the production of two different
things those two different things are
NADPH and ATP so it uses light energy to
power the production of these two
molecules where does this happen
in ProCare
it occurs along the plasma membrane
which is not really too important for
our discussion so I'm just going to skip
over that
but in plants it occurs in the
chloroplasts okay but where in the
chloroplasts okay
more specifically the thylakoid discs
and even more specifically along the
thylakoid membrane and shortly I'll be
talking about the anatomy of a
chloroplast so that this portion here
makes a little bit more sense so what is
the light reaction really it's a series
of redox reactions the series of redox
reactions that starts off by taking
water and turning it into oxygen right
that of course as we just mentioned
right was an oxidation reaction okay and
would this be a favorable or unfavorable
process so if we're taking water and
turning it into oxygen I don't know
about you but every time I see a glass
of water it does not turn into oxygen so
this process is extremely unfavorable
okay extremely unfavorable okay so it
requires energy right where does that
energy come from well from light okay
the energy from light drives the light
reactions of photosynthesis so of course
the redox reactions begin with turning
water into oxygen and it ends with
taking nadp+ and reducing it to NADPH so
let's see
process kind of Macy's nadph s and along
the way we establish a proton gradient
which we'll talk about in more detail
later which powers the production of of
a ATP okay and this here is called photo
phosphorylation which is a little bit
different then what we talked about with
the electron transport chain which is
oxidative phosphorylation the reason why
this is called photo phosphorylation is
because the entire process essentially
is driven by energy from light and photo
means light there are two photosystems
that are involved with the light
reaction and there they are photosystem
2 and photosystem 1 and you'll notice I
wrote photosystem 2 before photosystem 1
it's kind of weird why would I do that
the reason I wrote photosystem 2 before
photosystem 1 is that the order in which
they occur is two and then one so
photosystem two comes before photosystem
one okay and we'll see that the details
behind that later so what goes on in the
dark reaction right or the light
independent reaction the purpose of the
dark reaction is to use ATP and NADPH
from the light reaction from the light
reaction to make glucose to make glucose
which is of course C six loops c6 h-12
o-6 okay so for prokaryotes where this
occur the only place that they can occur
because prokaryotes don't have
organelles cellular organelles it would
occur in the cytosol again that's not
really too important for us for more
concerned with plants at least I am so
in plants they occur in the chloroplasts
but we're on the KO applies specifically
they clear occur in the stroma okay so
let me actually underline thylakoid
membrane over here for the light
reaction and underlying stroma that's
the the most important part
the dark reaction as you may have
already known is called Calvin cycle and
it's named for of course the person who
discovered it which was Mel who is
Melvin Calvin
the these steps of the dark reaction are
called carbon fixation steps we're
fixing carbon dioxide right they're also
called the carbon assimilation steps and
basically we're taking carbon dioxide
and reducing it right as a reductive
process to glucose and I wrote kinda
here and the reason why is because it's
of course more detail behind that and
we'll get to that in a future video okay
but that's sort of the general overview
of what's supposed to happen the light
reaction in the dark reaction now I do
need to talk about the anatomy of a
koala Plast just so that you're familiar
with it and that everything is
henceforth makes sense so if we think
about this chloroplast this chloroplast
is in the cytosol of a plant cell okay
so now this chloroplast itself has a
bunch of different structures that I've
labeled with all these white lines here
and I've wrote everything down here in E
versus a yellow or golden rod if you
will anyway it has these eight different
things okay that we're going to talk
about at least so a is the outer
membrane and that's this most outer
portion here right that outer membrane
this is a the outer membrane and of
course that's the outer membrane this
this membrane right just inside of it is
the inner membrane okay and the space
between them is the inter membrane space
now I breezed through that really quick
quickly because I don't really care
about those locations okay they're not
all too important for for understanding
photosynthesis there are portions that
are much more important okay so inside
of the chloroplast the space here that's
this this whole space here is called the
stroma okay and that loops I don't want
to write it all out I try to save myself
some time the stroma is labeled C that's
just the space bound by the inner
membrane of the chloroplast so this
entire space here is the stroma and
that's actually going to be pretty
important for us to think about okay
especially since that's where the calvin
cycle occurs it's also involved to some
degree in the light reaction which we'll
see later so in the chloroplast are
these little discs okay and they're in
stacks so these disks of course are the
thylakoid discs so this here is pointing
to actually one disc so that's going to
be a five liquid disc which is labeled
by F now that those these thyroids or
these delicate discs are you know they
have their own membranes okay which i've
labeled with this line here so that's of
course the thylakoid membrane anything
inside of the thylakoid is considered
the thylakoid space or the thylakoid
lumen which i've noted here okay and
that of course all of these locations
the thylakoid space the stroma the
thylakoid membrane are going to be very
important to consider when we're talking
about the reactions of photosynthesis
now when we have a stack of disks that's
basically just called the Granum and if
there's multiple multiple grand numb
there grana so that's what i've labeled
here with e okay so that's important to
keep in mind when we talking about the
reactions of photosynthesis hope that
was helpful thanks for watching